Film Courage: Lee I think you said that feature
writers should have a new, ready-to-market
feature script every six months or so.
And that TV writers should have a new original
pilot one every three or four months.
Lee Jessup: In a perfect world.
Yes…
Film Courage: Is that a lot of pressure though?
Lee Jessup: That’s a lot of pressure.
I find that most features go six to twelve
months.
You know the truth of the matter is if you
take 14 months and you come up with a great
sample, I’m not going to hold it against
you.
The important thing for me is that you keep
writing and keep finishing work.
For pilots in a perfect world, I would like
to see two generated in a year.
Sometimes it happens that it’s only one.
Sometimes it happens that it’s three.
It really depends on the writer.
So there isn’t really one set course that
you’re supposed to follow.
But it’s really about doing the work and
getting the work out there.
Sometimes you’ll work on a script and you’ll
say “I’ve worked on this for eight months.
I’ve tackled this every which way, it’s
not happening.”
It’s also knowing when to let something
go, not for all eternity but for potentially
you can come back to it later when you’ve
had a stroke of genius that informs you how
to take the work, how to make it better.
But the point with having those broad goals
is just do the work and get it out there rather
than spend years and years and years tinkering
with one screenplay that then you run the
risk that after three years (and I just went
through this with a writer), tinkering with
the script for three years and then going
“Oh, it’s not good enough.”
It will never be good enough.
I’m not going to get it out there.
And then starting another script and spending
another two years on something and then going
“Oh but it’s still not good enough.
I’m not going to get this out there.”
That is the challenge that we run into.
So because of that you really want to expose
the work early and often.
So that means from concept, you want to run
the concept by people in the know, whether
it be members of your writers group or in
a class or whatever it is.
Have people look at your outline.
Really don’t be afraid to expose the work
to get feedback to have questions asked.
I was just sitting with a writer of mine who
had written a feature script with a guy that
is his manager and they had been on the script
for a year and a half.
And then he gave the script to a few writer
friends.
And he got some massive notes back.
And what he’d said to me was “Oh, if only
we’d given it an outline.”
It was what we all were pushing him to do
but he felt loyal to the manager.
He didn't want to expose it.
And I understand that choice that he made.
He was sort of in a tough spot to serve [or]
to listen and to serve the one master.
Do you open yourself up?
I generally prefer to expose work early and
often because I just think that it saves you
a lot of time in the end.
Question for the Viewers: How many scripts
did you write last year?